this is a really exciting day and
exciting week with so many fantastic
activities
and one of the things that i like about
the vision of president salovey is the
idea that we'll interact more with the
new haven community that the yale will
foster entrepreneurial
developments aspects and in some sense
we each each of us have many of us have
little science teams which are
entrepreneurial in themselves and it
would be great for all of us to be
watching for spin-offs for the community
because i think that's really a
wonderful lovely idea to make the
area really vibrant
so i'm here today to talk to you about
my research on the detection of
exoplanets exoplanets are planets that
orbit other stars
this story started in 1995 when the
first planet was discovered orbiting a
sun-like star
and the reason that people thought this
was exciting is
captured here on the cover of time
magazine is anybody out there
so it wasn't so much the discovery of
rocks orbiting other stars that captured
our imagination and it's not why i do my
research it's because we're really
interested in whether or not there's
life out there and we see this as a path
uh to finding that to getting an answer
to that question
i will tell you in my conclusion so you
don't have to stay for the whole talk
that i think is actually inevitable i
don't see how there can not be life
elsewhere
so we've gone from 1995 when the
discovery of a single planet for several
years was um
front page news uh you know there were
documentaries lots of documentaries we
were whisked around uh in in limos to
talk on radio stations and so forth to
uh today 2013 when there are thousands
of planets that we know about
uh largely thanks to the kepler mission
nasa's kepler mission which has
discovered uh over 3 000 planet
candidates
we still need to confirm many of them to
call them bona fide planets but it seems
unambiguously clear that we're seeing
statistical trends that tell us about
the how often earth-like planets swarm
how often big jupiters form and so forth
when i was a graduate student at uc
santa cruz uh professor frank drake was
my professor of radio astronomy and he's
often known as the father of seti the
father of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and so
there's no doubt that he played an
enormous role in fostering my
interest in trying to figure out if
there could be life elsewhere and he
pinned uh standing behind or posted
behind him
onto the cosmos is this uh drake
equation which he penned which says that
the number of technological
civilizations is a product of several
terms and when he penned this equation
he didn't actually know the
what to fill in for for many of those
terms and indeed there are several
that are still ambiguous or still
uncertain today but many of them we have
begun to fill in we know how what the
star formation rate is now in the galaxy
we know how often stars form with
planets
and we know how often uh earth-like
planets form around other stars
so just to make sure we're all on the
same page i'll give you a super quick
review of our solar system
um our solar system we have of course
the the sun and then these tiny little
specks of planets
uh mercury venus earth and mars and then
saturn sorry jupiter saturn uranus
neptune and this guy has to be kicked
out now so we have eight planets and a
lot of rocky debris in the solar system
as well
so you can see already that like our
place
in the solar system is not too
impressive
most of the planets in our solar system
are on circular or near circular orbits
and of the eight planets only one of
them
is inhabited although we're looking for
signs of life on moons around jupiter
and on
subsurface at least fossils of life on
on mars that might tell us a lot about
how life got started in our solar system
zooming into our closest cousins so just
comparing for size
you can see that mars is quite a bit
smaller venus is a near twin of the
earth and and mercury is a tiny cratered
planet without much of an atmosphere
that orbits very close to the sun
since i'll be throwing around terms like
a jupiter-sized planet i wanted to let
you know that jupiter is about 300 times
the mass of the earth
saturn although it's the same size is
lower density it's about 95 times the
mass of the earth uranus is about 14
times it's mostly a rocky core with a
atmosphere thick atmosphere but nothing
like
jupiter or saturn and neptune is 17
earth masses
so these are the metrics that we use
when we start to look at other planetary
systems we say we're finding
neptune-like planets or jupiter-like
planets what we mean is that they're the
size or the mass of these planets
if we look at the engineering sketch of
our solar system you can see that
with the sun very close here
mercury venus earth and mars all orbit
in you know fairly tight orbits close to
the sun and then it's a big jump out to
jupiter
saturn and in fact the halfway point in
our solar system is um on the way to
uranus
so um how do other solar systems compare
to our own solar system how we found
them and what biases does that introduce
in our understanding of other solar
systems
the first technique to find an
earth-like planet was actually a pulsar
timing technique it looked at a star
that was no longer a normal star like
the sun burning hydrogen in its core but
a star that had evolved into a neutron
star it had exploded leaving but behind
a tiny rapidly spinning core and like a
lighthouse as the
as the star is spinning there's a
synchrotron beam that comes toward us
and we see it coming on and off as it
spins around
and we can measure the timing of the
pulses that we receive to figure out
that the star itself is coming towards
us and going away from us
and with enviable precision the
pulsar timing technique is was able to
to trace out the orbits of three planets
the scale on this by the way is
impossible to see but it's about these
ticks are a half a meter per second
so i'm not supposed to step away but a
half a meter per second all right about
that that distance each second we're
able to track the velocity of this
neutron star
now if we were to look at our solar
system remember that's a half a meter
per second
sort of min max on that scale
we would see that the sun is wobbling
around because of the planets that are
tugging it around a common center of
mass so we look at us we would look at a
spectrum of the sun and we would see the
absorption lines that form in the
atmosphere of the sun shifting blue word
and redward as the sun
comes toward us and goes away from us
and if we did this i have here a
theoretical plot now it's not a half a
meter per second which would be one sub
tick on this scale but jupiter
induces a reflex velocity of about 12
meters per second a velocity amplitude
and it takes about 12 years for the sun
to complete one of these orbits
saturn is the next biggest guy in our
solar system and in 30 years saturn tugs
the sun in a complicated orbit that is
about two and a half meter per second in
amplitude
so this is the what we thought we would
be looking for when we first started
searching for exoplanets if we're not
theorists but if we're observers then we
know that each one of our measurements
has an uncertainty an error that's
associated with it
and in the early days our measurement
uncertainty was anywhere from 10 to a
few meters per second i'll show you
eventually that we've worked really hard
to push that down
so in theory you'd have a data set that
looks like this you would pretty
confidently extract the blue curve which
is the model for jupiter but it would
you would be hard pressed i think to
find saturn in this data set
so in 1995 as i said the first planet
was discovered by our swiss colleagues
dda kulo who is a postdoctoral fellow
working with michelle mayor
and they were working at the oprah vols
observatory in
southern france
and here's their data set i promise i
won't show you too many data sets so
some there's some pretty pictures
and this is now a scale of kilometers
per second and they traced out over and
over this signal which was due to a
jupiter-like planet
but a jupiter-like planet that orbited
once every four days
okay mercury orbits once every 88 days
in our solar system okay so for a
jupiter-sized planet to orbit once every
four days means it has to be incredibly
close
to the sun
and these some of these hot jupiters
were nicknamed roasters
at first
the temperatures there range from 500 to
a few thousand degrees kelvin so these
are incredibly hot places
so um we uh the team that i worked with
uh was headed by jeff marcy and paul
butler
and by in 1995 they confirmed this
planet 51 peg that was discovered by our
our swiss colleagues
steve vogt was the instrument mil uh
builder who built the
all the instruments that we've used so
far at lick observatory in the keck
observatory and the younger version of
me was apparently catching starlight in
my hands and looking for the planets
there
i didn't find any that way but we did
find some looking at the doppler
technique looking at the spectra of
stars and watching it go back and forth
by 1999 we had discovered the first
triple planet system so
the first time that there was a jupiter
again like the like 51 peg this was in a
something like four day orbit and we
could see the trend in our data that
suggested there would be another planet
out here orbiting roughly every two and
a half years
and when i modeled the data i found a
third planet in the system so this was
actually quite a surprise no one
expected jupiter's to be close to the
stars and we didn't expect jupiter's to
be packed in like this to to fill up the
space around stars so tightly
we've gone from 1999 and the incredible
discoveries there
to this past year
i think the record breaker is a the
detection of a planet orbiting alpha
centauri so alpha centauri a and b
are a binary star system that means the
two stars orbit each other and in
addition a planet was found orbiting one
of the stars alpha centauri b
now this is indeed a bona fide earth
mass planet
but it's in a three-day orbit so they're
probably unless there are asbestos
people living on the surface of the
planet it's probably not a great place
for life there's also another star in
the system maybe it's depicted here
proxima centauri so this is actually a
triple star system
and this has been one of the surprises
to us how incredibly robust this process
of planet formation
seems to
be so
in this figure i'm showing you the mass
of the planets that we detect
and the orbital periods of the planets
so just to guide your eye i've dropped
in jupiter which has an orbital period
as i said roughly 12 years and of course
the earth has an orbital period of 11
years and we have reason to believe that
earth-like planets are a good place for
life to form right we're here
but there's also
i think evidence from uh system
chemistry that we know about now that
suggests that you know it's life will
get started on a planet like this so i
put in some uh bars to sort of guide
your eye this is called the habitable
zone and this is the region which is a
distance from the star the orbital
period gets longer as you go farther
away from the star so it's a distance
from the star where it's not too hot
it'd be really hot here
and not too cold
but just right the goldilocks zone so
that liquid water can reside on the
surface of the planet
we also think it's important that the
planet's not too big it can't be too
small mars lost its water because it
wasn't able to hang on to its atmosphere
and so we want a planet that's something
like the mass of the earth but it's
possible that a planet that's a few
times the mass of the earth could still
be a perfectly good place for life so
now i'll just show you the history of
how
things have gone we'd like to find
planets as i said in this overlap region
in the venn diagram here
that's the habitable zone and just the
right mass
so the first planets that we detected
1995 96 98 you can see time ticking by
we found the biggest ones first that was
a selection bias because they were
exerting the largest tug on their host
stars they were the easiest to see
but as time went on we began detecting
lower and lower mass planets
however there's a bias if you're going
to detect a low mass planet then the
ones that are closest
at least are helped by the
the fact that the gravitational force
falls off as one over distance squared
but you can see that this region of
space is still not populated
so i think that we
here at yale my group here at yale is in
an excellent position
i have an instrumentation group and
we've been working very hard we built a
spectrograph in chile
after we built it and tested it we went
back and refurbished the optics and what
i've shown here is
just it qualitatively to give you a
sense this is the sort of errors the
uncertainties in our measurements
circa
early 2000 and now with the development
that we've done
with chiron in chile
this is what our velocity precision
looks like so we're able to measure uh
precisions the motion of stars to about
a half a meter per second now what that
means for earth
is it's encouraging it means that the
earth induces a velocity in the sun of
about 10 centimeters per second so we're
a factor of five away but we're no
longer a factor of 10 or 100 away which
is where we were when we started this
game
so with this technique that i use it's
called the doppler technique sometimes
in the press it's called the wobble
technique
we've detected uh more than 500 uh
planets so 533 is the count as of today
planets that were detected with this
technique but you can see maybe you
yourselves are skeptical you look at the
plot and you believe me because i say
i'm an astronomer
and then i look for planets so you
believe me that i'm showing you data
that actually reflects a picture like
this right
however even scientists were skeptical
in the first few years
they they saw our data they thought it
was lovely they doubted the
interpretation that it was a planet that
we were seeing they thought maybe the
star itself was pulsating or maybe we
were looking at based on binaries there
were many
sorts of alternative explanations and so
we knew that we had to wait until we
happened to observe a system which was
nearly edge-on to our line of sight it's
just a matter of chance right orbits are
randomly uh oriented randomly tilted as
we as we look all around the uh galaxy
so but we knew that for these close-in
planets that roughly one out of ten
would pass in front of its host star
and when it did that that that process
is called a transit when it does that it
dims the light of the star ever so
slightly for a few hours so we were
checking every single one of those early
systems we got to you know eight nine
ten we were sure we were gonna you know
one out of ten and it was number eleven
but that's okay
number eleven transited its host star
the picture is like this the background
star the planet goes in front of it as
we view it so it's a very serendipitous
observation
and the data actually look like this so
here's what we measure okay we never see
this picture we put that in our artists
to put that in for you but we measure
the brightness of the star and we see
that it dips for a few hours as the
planet goes across the face of the star
and then when the planet
undergoes egress or exits the the disc
of the star the star brightens back up
okay so this transit technique i think
clinched the deal for most astronomers
from most scientists and convinced
people that indeed what we were looking
at were planets
since then we've actually looked at not
just transit but we've seen the
atmosphere of the planets boiling off
okay these planets are very close to
their host stars and so there's
quite a bit of evaporation and
mass loss of the atmosphere of the
planet
what i love though is that it's this
combination of the technique that i do
measuring the radial velocities and the
transit technique that is an absolute
watershed of data if you think about it
the technique that i use gives us the
mass of the planet
we don't know the tilt remember that's
why we had to keep looking for 11 times
before we found one that was oriented
edge on but once we do see that it
transits we know the tilt so we know the
mass of the planet
and now
the amount of dimming that we measure
from the planet tells us the size of the
planet relative to the size of the star
if the planet were as big as a star of
course it wouldn't be a planet anymore
but if it were the star would blink out
and the smaller you make the planet the
smaller the decrease in light is when it
transits in front of it
so if we have the size of the planet and
we have the mass of the planet then we
can easily calculate the mean density of
the planet we can begin to make models
of what the plant using these boundary
conditions the total mass the size of
the planet what we understand about the
interior of planets like jupiter and
saturn and now you know i can show you a
probably reasonable crash section of a
planet that orbits a star i can't even
see if i go out in the night sky right i
need powerful telescopes just to see the
star we never see the planet and yet we
get this incredible amount of
information and i think this is such a
monument um to the achievements
collective achievements of humankind
that were pushed the envelope like this
and and get this kind of incredible
information
with this technique of looking at tr
looking for transiting planets from the
ground um more than three about 387
planets as of today have been detected
that number always goes up
uh and then uh because of the success of
this technique and because it's so
powerful and giving us the density of
the planet and allowing us to look at
the atmosphere as the planet transits
nasa launched the kepler mission in 2009
so the nasa kepler mission went up and
stared at one part of the sky which had
three million stars the scientists
picked 180 000 of those stars to follow
very carefully the kepler spacecraft
beamed down the data on in regular
intervals to the earth and the
scientists looked to see if among those
and eighty thousand stars any of them
were dimming very slightly for a few
hours
and this has been an absolutely stunning
success
uh the kepler technique the kepler
mission has found
as i said more than
000 planets orbiting other stars but it
told us something very important
remember that the technique that i'm
using found the most massive planets
first and the small planets low mass
planets like the earth which we really
do care about in terms of searching for
life are really tough to find
with that technique but the kepler
mission had the sensitivity to detect
them
it also showed us that these multiple
planet systems like the upsilon
andromeda system that we found are very
common
so here's a sort of a schematic now
comparing a system called kepler 11 to
our solar system here's the the sun
mercury which is in an eccentric orbit
and venus and there are in this kepler
11 system one two three four five six
planets inside of venus's orbit okay six
small planets so planet formation is
incredibly robust a very rich process
and nature has surprised us at how
efficient it is at building and packing
in planets
we also found we found planets i told
you that alpha centauri a and b were a
binary star system where a and b orbit
each other and then proxima's way out
here and in a very long orbit it comes
around a and b as well
and we wondered whether or not planets
might get kicked out so
we found one planet orbiting alpha
centauri b could there be planets that
go around both of the stars
and in fact the kepler mission uh was
successful at finding a system this is
the planet which orbits every 250ish
days and it orbits two stars a large a
hot star hotter than our sun even and a
little m dwarf star but both of these
are our actual stars so if we were on
this planet we look up in the sky and we
would see two suns in our sky two suns
on the horizon so that would be quite a
spectacular thing the two stars would
always be close together because the the
orbital period of these two stars is
fairly short so it would be quite
spectacular
and of course
um
this is a
star wars right in star wars luke
skywalker lived on the system called
tatooine where in fact that was the view
from his planet and so uh nasa wisely
cashed in on that publicity and and
called this uh planet tatooine it was
nicknamed tatooine
so the kepler mission has found uh many
systems this is uh dan fabricky who's a
professor at the university of chicago
has been modeling the stability of these
systems and he put together these oris
which sort of make your head spin
but to just to show you how incredibly
rich the systems are right you see
orbits
orbital precession with planets orbiting
each other and and their stars is quite
quite amazing
so we now know that in fact most uh
planets planetary architectures um
contain
uh
multi-planet systems the greatest quote
that i love we didn't know this before
the kepler mission was launched is this
quote by the the pi bill baruchi who
said very simply practically all
sun-like stars have planets and there's
all sorts of statistics but i've just
highlighted one here for you 50 of stars
have planets between 1.2 and 4 times the
mass of the earth so those are the
planets in that one blue zone that i
highlighted on the plot
and now we have to see how many
intersect in the venn diagram in the
so-called habitable zone
from this
mission actually this number should be
updated it's over 3000 now
so there's another technique for finding
planets and it's called microlensing and
i think it has to win the prize for
being the coolest technique ever just
because of the principle that it uses
so whenever i show this next slide i
have to talk really fast so i'm going to
try and say some of it first that with
micro lensing if there's a background
star let's say that exit sign over there
across the room which i'm looking at
from earth
and another planet were to pass between
us
then it turns out that a property of
mass is that it warps the space-time
continuum around it in fact most
physicists are thinking that the thing
we call gravity and thought was a
fundamental force all along is some
attribute or some you know
something that just has to do with mass
which we now think we have we understand
less than ever
okay so the planet goes the star goes
between us if it hosts some planets then
i'm going to see brightening as and the
reason i'd see brightening is because
normally i would only see the rays of
light that come directly to my eye from
that exit sign from that background star
but when the space time continuum is
warped then the uh rays are bent around
this space and and it act the uh the
star and planetary system act like a
gravitational lens so there's a
temporary brightening in what i see
okay so here's the cartoon here's the
observatory the background star here's
the lens star which is going in between
us these are the data we're collecting
it brightened up there because the lens
star went through and then there was a
second brightening
uh from the planet which was also
warping space-time
so this technique has found now
something like 21
planets around other stars and it's cool
because well it's cool because it warps
the space-time continuum come on
but it's also cool because it helps
probe the planets that are at at larger
distances than either the transit
technique or the doppler technique uh
can do so we're trying to put together
an inventory
and understand planets uh that are close
and in wide orbits and so far the ones
that are missing are planets like our
own the earth's inhabitable zones
um an exciting technique and of course
what we'd all like to do is direct
imaging i would love to go to the
observatory take a picture of a star
planet sitting next to it i'm done write
up the paper
instead you know i have to obtain data
night after night year after year to map
out the orbit
of the star due to the planet so i have
to rely on the time allocation
committees to be patient with my project
as we accumulate these long strings of
data
so direct imaging is super exciting
because in fact this very week
may be affected by the government
shutdown but this very week in chile
there's a team that's commissioning a
new instrument that will do very deep
imaging it will block out the the star
itself so that it can see the images of
planets orbiting the star and that's
where we have to get so that we can
start looking taking a spectra of the
atmospheres of those planets and figure
out what's in the atmospheres
so far this
technique has discovered something like
31 exoplanets okay but they tend to be
very massive planets as you can imagine
they have to be bright like jupiter and
fairly young so so that it's still a
luminous jupiter
okay so there are lots of observational
techniques i've described now the
doppler technique that i use the transit
technique um the micro lensing and
direct imaging techniques
so of all of these different techniques
um how many will find earth's
and how will we find many earths because
we can probably it's probably a safe bet
that if we
look at one single earth that we're not
guaranteed defined life on it that life
might not be so ubiquitous so robust
that it always gets started so we'd like
to have a reasonable sample size
um i think
a question i was asked back in 1997 in
fact was
so you found one you know you're finding
jupiter-like planets will your technique
ever be able to find earth and at the
time i started to say no and then i
caught myself and said you know
i don't know how we'll get there now
today um but i'm sure we'll keep pushing
and then we'll have to see that's how
science is that there aren't you know if
i could guarantee you the results it
wouldn't be science it wouldn't be
original um basic research
so um i now believe that in fact the
doppler technique can find earth so we
found 533
one of them is the mass of the earth
zero or at earth-like distances in the
habitable zone but as i said we're
pushing very hard
to improve our precision so that we'll
be sensitive to earth-like planets
now
why earths so usually i'll give a talk
this might be the end of my talk and
then people will say but why are you so
focused on earth
and i think the answer is that that's
this is the best place
that we can look because it optimizes
our chances of being able to detect life
to recognize life
and in the past few years i've been
teaching for the last decade now some
version of a course called life in the
universe
and in the and i've watched the
evolution of you know biologists trying
to figure out how life got started in on
this planet and in the last two or three
years the most exciting research ever
from my perspective has emerged and it's
centered on ideas around what's called
system chemistry
so there has been for 50 years now an
idea that rna is a can replicate itself
rna is a template for for life you know
rna is basically
the the core of a virus so maybe rna is
is how the the molecule that bridges
chemistry and biology
but some experiments that have been done
by gerald joyce who's at the scripps
institute shows that if he takes a
couple of strands of rna and puts them
into a nice rich solution where the
nucleic acid bases are available for for
the rna to both replicate and to evolve
into different types of strands
that the population begins to rapidly
evolve and the rnas explore this
landscape
of reaction rates
and that what you end up with a couple
days later
is our rna temp our rna strands which
cross catalyze each other
so it's not autocatalysis it's not that
it's reproducing itself it's that it
evolves into they evolve into helper
molecules
and since this
the reaction rates win
right it's a kind of system chemistry
that suggests that life wasn't a freak
accident you know this this transition
from chemistry to biology wasn't a freak
accident but that it was actually almost
inevitable
so once you figure out once nature
figures out a way to form the rna
molecules and many ways are proposed for
that it doesn't seem like a show stopper
stage to me
then by virtue of having different types
of rna the system simply evolves
governed entirely by reaction rates into
something
you know that reproduces and replicates
and goes quickly forward
so if that's true on this planet it's
likely to be true on other planets um
alternatively i often ask biologists so
you know we talk a lot about the last
common ancestor and the tree of life
there are archaea bacteria eukaryotes on
the tree of life
and what they have in common is that
they're all carbon based they use 20 of
the hundreds of possible amino acids the
amino acids that they use all have a
particular chirality left-handed
chirality and only interact with
right-handed sugars so you can and they
all use dna to replicate themselves uh
so so you can list all these things and
so i asked biologists so what if there
was life on this planet that didn't do
those things would you recognize it
and i'm sort of that question is almost
always met with silence so if it's hard
to and you know uh and and and they say
i don't know that the weird life the
truly weird life would be tough to
recognize even if it's sitting right
here on our lab benches right so if
we're going to have a hard time
recognizing it here on our lab benches
then let's look for life that we can
recognize on other planets it really
reinforces my my sense that what we want
to look at are our earths look for
earth's inhabitable zone distances where
there's liquid water and the kind of
chemistry that we believe will take off
okay and and inevitably form life but
then businessmen will say but wait what
are the practical applications of your
work
at which point i launch into
okay three things people number one
consider our place in space so it's
going to be a long-winded answer okay
but i already told you that our little
planet is insignificant compared in our
solar system and if we zoom out into our
whole galaxy with billions of stars you
know we're something like halfway out in
our galaxy our sun is an unremarkable
star it's just like billions of others
in the universe and in fact humans have
often wondered astronomers of wonder
they looked up at a part of the sky
that's kind of close to the big dipper
and they thought it's kind of odd there
aren't any stars there it's a dark
region of the sky it's really boring so
let's take the hubble space telescope
and have the hubble space at hubble
orbits once every 92 minutes so as the
hubble space telescope is coming around
open the shutter look at this tiny part
of the sky which is just by the way a
tiny fraction of the size of the moon
and after hubble exposed for the
equivalent of 10 days open shutter time
the image that was obtained in this
completely dark part of the sky where
nothing was seen was 10 000 galaxies
so the richness of our universe in terms
of the number of galaxies you know each
one of these
perhaps something like a milky way okay
billions of other uh galaxies is really
humbling okay that's still not an answer
but stick with me
okay so our place in space is small now
what about the rareness of our
composition
if we were to take a fair sample of the
universe that means i have a box that's
big enough to scoop up enough of the
universe so that i get a representative
sample of all of the constituents and
the sort of structure of the universe
then
i reached in and grabbed something out
it would never be anything i mean it
would improv very unlikely be anything
that's like us
okay if you open the box the first thing
that comes out is this incredible stream
of electromagnetic radiation um as caleb
scharf says in his book gravity's engine
a heaving soup of unseen photons are
racing across eternity they don't stop
unless they interact with matter
so
if you consider just one cubic
centimeter like a sugar cube um that
cubic centimeter will contain hundreds
of photons which are from the big bang
the the universe is expanded and cooled
but right in here in this room we're
immersed in the remnants of the big bang
okay most of the stuff if you want to
get to the periodic table of elements is
hydrogen and helium the stuff that we're
made out of carbon oxygen
hydrogen as well nitrogen that's rare
stuff
there's a lot of neutrinos
and other exotic particles one of the
things that we've learned is that
the stuff in the fair sample is really
the thing that's really startling is
that most of the stuff in there in the
fair sample
is something that we have no idea what
it is we've nicknamed it dark matter
we only know it exists because we see
how it affects the
material like stars that we think we
understand
and dark matter
it drifts through solid matter it moves
slowly and it outweighs normal matter by
a factor of five
okay so that was bad enough but at the
time i was thinking of being an
astronomer because then i could study
everything in the universe
our ability to understand what the
universe actually started shrinking so
we're now i say an order of magnitude
behind because we discovered that
there's also something else dark energy
the universe is expanding all those
galaxies you saw are flying apart from
each other from one another
and so there has to be some kind of
essentially some kind of energy that
would cause an acceleration we've called
that dark energy we don't understand it
at all we don't know if it's something
odd about um about the uh
the space space-time continuum at very
large distances um but what we do know
is that if you make up a pie diagram
okay of the stuff that we understand
most of it is dark energy the next big
chunk is dark matter okay those are
names they're placeholder names we have
absolutely no idea what they are
and then you end up with stuff that we
can touch stuff that we understand it's
mostly hydrogen it's mostly in stars and
then of the stuff that's like us 0.03
percent
of the universe is in elements in the
periodic table that are heavy elements
like like our planet
okay so that's two are we're where where
places our place in space is small we're
very rare stuff okay but it gets worse
consider our place in time
so the big bang occurred 13.6
it's been upgraded now 8 billion years
ago
so but i don't understand what that
means i mean i my lifetime is so short
and respect but carl sagan's genius was
to say let's take from the moment of the
big bang is january 1st and right now
there's a one year that's gone by it's
the cosmic calendar
the clock is just about to tick over
into another year so now we can remap
all of the time into this cosmic
calendar and find out that in the
springtime our galaxy forms for a long
time the universe is here doesn't know
you know we we're even our galaxy
doesn't exist our sun forms roughly in
august what's really remarkable is that
the varnish of life the beginning of
life begins in late august and september
okay so very quickly but for a long time
it's simple cell organisms that are
ruling the planet
if we want to zoom in and see wait where
are we on the cosmic calendar some
people get very worried at this point we
have to go to december
now the dinosaurs which of course
appeared so long ago
appear on
christmas day on this calendar and they
rule the earth until december 30th on
this calendar so now i'm very
uncomfortable because i don't understand
where humanity the most important
species that's ever ruled been on the
planet is going to come in
and in fact it's coming in in the last
seconds of the year depending on how if
you wanted to find the first appearance
of early hominids then you can go back a
couple of hours but by the time we get
here to
i guess christ born you know we're six
seconds away columbus arrives in america
one second before midnight
what about technological humans okay the
the our species that can build radio
telescopes they can ask questions like
was there a big bang and where did the
molecules and atoms in our body come
from okay technological humans have been
here for a millisecond on this cosmic
calendar
the dinosaurs were here for a whole week
they did nothing to advance knowledge
right they munched on each other they
munched on the grass
so if we've been here for a millisecond
where are we going to be if we get to be
here for hours on the cosmic calendars
for a week on the cosmic calendar i'm
pretty sure that we will be going out
into exploring the galaxy
so my answer finally sorry it was
long-winded but
it was a bad question
is that we do not dominate the universe
in any sense our place in space is small
we're the rarest of stuff and we're
newcomers to this planet and yet look at
who we are okay that we have the
audacity that we have the talent to be
able to build
observatories monuments to cathedrals
really to mankind's curiosity about the
universe and to discover our place in a
way that no other species on this planet
has ever found discovered right there is
something about our nature all right
that wants to discover that wants to
learn that needs to feel awe that needs
to understand these things
and we can't just look the other way i
think we we need to keep going um in
this direction there have been many mass
extinctions of course while the
dinosaurs were munching on the grass
an asteroid came in and hit the yucatan
peninsula and extinguished life there
and so we on the other hand have the
ability to look up we're monitoring the
near-earth asteroids right we're
understanding the things that are
impacting our planet that are that are
challenges to our habitability um and i
think we will address those as a species
i have absolutely no doubt that we will
address these and that we'll get move
past
this this phase that we're in now of new
modern technological man
um so i'll for the entertainment portion
of my talk i have a youtube video that i
found that i'd like to show you in some
sense it encapsulates for me you know an
education at yale because it shows how
astronomy kind of weaves through our
culture how it's related to who we are
but as you watch this remember that
although the video focuses on sort of
modern
man
that that's just the last seconds of the
cosmic calendar
so here we go and if the sound's on yeah
perfect
so as i uh in my talk now i'll show you
some pictures of observatories around
the world
and say to you
mr businessman
that if you run a business and if you're
truly successful that part of your
business is most of your business is
just the daily operations of making
things happen but part of your business
has to be to have to have vision to have
a big plan to see the future and that
astronomy is an important part of the
vision plan for humans it's going to
help us to address
all of the critical issues that we're
facing in the future and i think it's a
cornerstone of a fundamental education
for our students here at yale thank you
so i believe if you have questions that
there are people with microphones who
can answer them or can pass you the
microphone and i try to answer them
yeah i have a question about the
techniques that you used whether they
overlapped at all the micro lensing the
kepler
and the doppler did they did any of them
find the same planets or were they all
different and was that because of where
they were or yeah could you explain that
a bit awesome question that's that is
that because that's the coolest thing
ever right to find the same thing with a
different technique and yes indeed we
have used transit techniques to confirm
radial velocity observations the kepler
field had serendipitously there were a
few stars in that field which had been
observed for a long time with
ground-based techniques and were
confirmed by kepler
the micro lensing actually sees a more
distant part of
planetary architectures so in terms of
particular mapping particular stars
that technique stands alone as being a
statistical technique
and not being able to contribute just
because of the serendipitous nature of
having to have the object pass behind a
background bright source
but then the direct imaging technique
and i really believe that in the next
year
or two you're going to hear a lot about
the g pi instrument which is being
commissioned right now in chile it will
look at the closest star systems and at
stars where we found planets and try and
image the planets around them so we're
definitely drilling down
one of the challenges is that as as
incredibly bountiful as the kepler
technique has been
most of the stars that it looks at are a
thousand light years away i want to take
a census of the closest 200 stars
find you know at least 100 earths around
them so that the this will form the the
first step the foundation for exploring
the nearby
solar system or our nearest neighbors
let's go spy on them yeah
okay there's a question down here
um i think she'll bring the microphone
yes i i wanted to ask about the adaptive
optic technique and by directly seeing
the planets um
what you're hoping to discover in them
and whether or not this requires a very
large telescope or if it could be done
say with a one meter telescope
you're a telescope
exactly
um
so
i think
you you'll need a large telescope to
collect a lot of photons and so
for the very first steps where we're
learning to develop adaptive optics
techniques i think it's brilliant i
absolutely believe and build a little
test a little build a little test a
little so that you go along a logical
path trying to start from zero and then
just go to the world's biggest telescope
and make it happen there is not an
efficient way to do business to do this
kind of business so i think that all of
these facilities have some role and what
we're trying to do is you know of course
uh have a way of blocking out the light
from the central star like i just did
now i can see all of you wow
and then seeing the planets that are
that are in the region and the reason
that we want to see them is we want to
look at the atmospheres of these planets
and the atmosphere is going to be a
tell-tale sign of life
any
uh astrophysicist worth their salt
living on a planet around alpha centauri
and looking back at the earth who saw a
21
composition of oxygen in this planet
given its location temperature pressure
and so forth would know that there has
to be aerobic life on this planet life
that's making use of the oxygen and life
that continues to pump oxygen into the
atmosphere so
it may not be the same signature that we
have here on this planet but i think
we'll find things that seem like they're
out of equilibrium out a chemistry
that's out of equilibrium and therefore
is a smoking gun for life
i thought i thought it was very
interesting that you were able to put
all of the galaxies in a box
what's outside the box
more galaxies
so the box that you saw i think you're
talking about the hubble deep field that
was seen from the dark part
oh the cube with the whole structure oh
wow
you're asking the hardest question of
all so
are the other cubes that is a great
question
all we can do is we can only see what we
call the observable universe and the
observable universe began with a big
bang and we can see you know back when
we look at most distant galaxies we're
looking back in time as well
um we can't see out of our box
so if there are other galaxies other
sorry other universes parallel universes
there we simply can't we have no way of
seeing them at this time
so but remember one millisecond on the
cosmic calendar give us a week and maybe
we'll solve that problem
yeah
okay if there aren't any other questions
then thanks so much for attending